you got this you're killing you're
crushing it everyone loves you be you
don't even worry about it he says
anything
so i say
brick house
i just take it out of my
this is what i say i don't even know why
i haven't thought of this song breakouts
i am not i like that that was in your
wedding i don't even know where it came
from
the rest of the night
you ever met this guy oh i'm the dumb
one you can't argue there's something
about me you have no idea what you're
saying
[Music]
buzz bug
oh what you got there buddy
oh damn thank you i did the same i did
the same thing i just got a regular gold
one yeah but i'd [ __ ] all that because
i'll lose it so i just i don't know
are you used to it yet i'm not yet um
yeah good day but how tight is that
though nah it's good yeah me that's what
it is but if i put soap it'll come off
yeah yeah me too you know what i mean
but that's why sometimes i like i take
it off when i'm washing my hands or
whatever it's like that just to get used
but i haven't really i don't feel it
doesn't feel yeah you know i've never
worn the ring i hate i don't i don't
like rings but i told my god
i wanted to get like a one of those dope
man rings that's like something it's
thicker and like yeah but then i was
like what what rogan has that yeah think
what
does he wear a rubber one the rubber
oh no no i'm talking about they're like
some of them like it's like they look
like three layers oh no there might be
diamonds in the middle or something like
that that would be very like a chris
angel ring that'd be sick yeah i like
that or where you're like your class
ring yeah like a super bowl right yeah i
wanted to get a tattoo but she was like
i actually don't remember i don't know i
don't get the argument it's forever i
don't remember where we fell on that
just do it i don't know it's cool it
looks cool with the watch though yeah it
doesn't match the watch it is i mean
it's just kind of like yeah you kind of
feel tethered i hate brands
yeah you're not a but you're a girl yeah
i like necklaces i like bracelets i just
hate [ __ ] on my fingers it just it seems
annoying i don't know
i don't know it's like an old school i
don't know philly is old school well
married man
yeah yeah things are you guys are acting
different you're the same
acting differently you're just dead oh
no i got it
i really do i feel like you know yeah um
you guys have the same wedding band too
i know that's did you get a discount or
how to make a a week well as the
department as the you know
the veteran of marriage yes yeah yeah i
call them every week and i say what what
do i expect this week well it's week two
yeah yeah yeah yeah
but this one is a doozy
yeah week two get ready
was that the picture i took
oh that's a good picture it's a good
pick yeah you had i really enjoyed your
wedding me too yeah thanks because it
wasn't long drawn out yeah yeah yeah too
serious yeah the valves were easy also
we got to work on the mic situation
right the audio okay because your vows
become hurt i was furious i was
i can't describe the rage i had when
they were messing up your
vows and then the lady who was like the
leader of it
her mic worked on like yeah
give your mic to him yeah right that was
the that was the whole crowd was saying
that it was almost turned into a thing
give up your mom yeah
it's okay though and uh we we got it on
video so right right yeah yeah it just
wasn't it just wasn't uh yeah a ton of
times um
well we might
watch it not a ton no you watch it once
yeah yeah it's nice to have though
it starts out though but then also the
the your your brother's speech was
fantastic
she was that funny when i brought him on
the road yeah i know he's the best of
his life that's good look at bobby bobby
also dressed up for mine and didn't
dress up for yours how do you feel about
that well he probably got heat oh he's
like he told me well that's what he said
the first time when he walked in he was
like i said oh you dressed up for her
and he was like
he was like i got so much heat i can't i
didn't
rick glassman did your uh yeah oh that's
great he was great yeah rick's the best
yeah yeah i've been to santa barbara in
a hot second either it's nice it's
changed man there's a bunch
dude that area is really great um that
area is a great picture did you see that
picture than your dad probably which one
right there that's his dad oh that's
sweet yeah yeah oh yeah your dad's so
nice man it's a trip to see my dad with
all like my buddies it's just such a
trip to see like
because also he
has been there like when i started doing
stand-up and he like knew all you guys
in the beginning and [ __ ] it's just like
wild like he took a picture with max
amini and i was like god damn it he's
known him forever yeah your dad uh
grabbed me when uh i think you were
doing the first dancing grab me he's
like i can't believe
we didn't meet before oh i know yeah
i know i know it's crazy we have not
said it's crazy
all right i know it's crazy yeah it was
good man and father's day dude too one
two oh right all right then yeah
for you
sort of day you know you're working
which is disrespectful yeah yeah that's
disrespectful to your culture
um i didn't know it was a holiday today
that's how white i am
well because it was yesterday right yeah
well i knew it was a holiday because my
kid had school his summer oh okay and i
was like why because it drives me nuts
when they have random days off like oh
yeah awareness yeah yeah yeah you're
making [ __ ] up yeah yeah and then he's
like oh dad i don't have camp tomorrow
i'm like why don't you have camp you
think it's some june i'm like oh
june 10 wow well you know it's about
time y'all yeah
well i said back to you i said what
y'all have done baby ian made me laugh
ian edwards made me laugh yesterday dude
he was
uh
he's he's black if for those of you that
don't know but he was like great comic
but he oh dude monster yeah great so
good but he [ __ ] was like someone was
somebody said it was we were gonna we
were gonna surprise you for juneteenth
because he was like the only black guy
around and he said he said yeah they did
too
dude that [ __ ] killed me
he's so funny dude he's so funny
dude but you know what made me laugh was
your [ __ ] comment back to david
arnold on your instagram when you said
sorry you got married before the
internet
dude that made me laugh do it he put me
he put he posted me on his instagram and
he was like wedding continues everyone's
getting married and then david arnold
was like talk to me when you guys get to
19 years and he said sorry you got
married before the internet liar i
laughed out loud that's funny because he
was just talking what it was he didn't
even look at the picture i just thought
he thought he was doing posting about
your posting
you know what i mean and i just was like
come on man so funny dude well you uh
there it is
yeah man
um can't you be proud bro you know
but also uh
how
you know what by the way just with
comments people think that's some sort
of like free press you know what do you
mean what i mean like they think it's
the free like they're a part of the free
press oh so they get to go into your
comments and talk about stuff that has
nothing to do with you know so i tell
you what man i i have just oh yeah i've
i all i've been doing is deleting oh
yeah yeah comments yeah you know what i
mean i'm like this is my this is our
happy day i know it's insane like i
don't need your help for wedding picks
just just yeah just what people were
putting out there just like guys
whatever put that on your page but even
the russian bots those [ __ ] i'll post
my son and the russians i'm an idiot
like dude who wants to get sucked off
today yeah i'm like no it's a picture of
my kids hey russian bots have a little
respect i do respect
i know i respect how they don't
discriminate posts
i i do respect that you post one like
your dad died or some [ __ ] you guys been
getting like
text messages from like random like i've
done they go like this they'll go like
hey bobby or hey dan you're right
and they got me because once it was like
hey it's blah blah blah and i was and i
have a friend with that name i'm like oh
you changed your number are you still in
blah blah and then he was like uh no
come on it's ryan from san francisco and
like oh oh this is a fake thing and then
once you just give them a little kernel
bro
30 random tags really hey it's
larry oh that's funny you know you're
like oh [ __ ] oh wow no yeah i never once
you give him a colonel it's off to the
right it's always like a fake asian girl
and she says
you know this is soon so whatever and
then i go is this so-and-so and i go no
it's not first time i every day i was
like no i don't what no i don't think i
get the wrong once you respond it's on
and then she go then they'll go oh well
you know i like meeting new people and
i'm like oh
that's hilarious you know what i mean it
just turns into this thing yeah because
they're hoping to get money because
you're like me new people and those
lonely dudes out there like
me too
and then it's i don't think you're
talking about somebody send me your
website that i can do that i'm not gonna
look at it right
here let me catch up you now to stop
dude
do you
uh
yeah how much you're gonna cost for you
to next time tell your friends that do
this too just stop here's 30 bucks dude
um
i know guys that have been got bro like
they sent dick pics and they're like
then they're like seventy five thousand
dollars that's and harry you know guys
too by the way oh i actually i know no
one you know what i'm talking about yeah
yeah yeah i don't want dude that got got
like that yeah yeah but then he was like
amy from ireland guys like cool no
it's a facebook facebook yeah yeah yeah
yeah and they they start talking and
they make it all sexy and they might
send some titty pics or something and
then like send this back and then they
screenshot everything and they're like
we're going to send this to your to your
job we're going to send this to your
boom boom that's awesome my buddy was
like oh i'm a comedian first of all i
[Laughter]
mike's taking it the lights all perfect
yeah
we uh got it gets up and moves the
camera
nick walks by
i thought it was dope at your wedding it
was a picture thing where people take
the pictures oh yeah yeah that was good
i came solo like a loser yeah but i had
no way to take a picture with so
exciting i'll do it with you man so
we're going to take one but we're going
to pretend that we are holding brian and
theo
yeah what with the lady taking place
like let's cut that out you two get
together right now
it was fun
that picture you and me with the picture
me and chris my mom goes eric's sexy all
right man you know what
your mom trying to smash i think so man
sorry two weeks too late i know you're
two weeks yeah my mom that's why i told
her and that's the first time i met your
fiance yeah your kids are me i'm sorry
your wife you're kidding me big like so
her dad's 16 dude her dad yeah at the
wedding he hugged
her dad dick in your face dude he was
like yeah man her dad's it was really
because he's always one of the tallest
dudes did did hit did her dad come and
talk to you
because he watches podcasts because
really so he was like walking around
like he was like oh take your shoes off
that's funny and he was like oh yeah
he knows all the stuff did he do
anything with it yeah he played
basketball for a little while oh thank
god i want level though
he he was like semi-pro he was trying to
be yeah all right all right that's good
that's good that's good bro i had one of
your friends i'm not throwing any [ __ ]
when your friends come over i'm
literally i'm i was so hungry the food
came food was delicious so i'm scarf i
was so hungry i'm scarfing it down
trying to stay on my diet scarfing down
and there's who whoever was around me i
think was craig and then marshall they
got up to get drinks so there's two
empty seats yeah and everybody sat down
he knew from back in day i guess he's a
high school wrestling coach yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh dude and i look one of
my best friends
all right that's great but rising coach
sits down he goes i've been dying to ask
you man
i coach high school wrestling yeah some
kids that want to get involved in mma
yeah yeah i mean where do you even start
oh yeah i went like this
what yeah it was where did he even start
i was like you know there's a lot of
hard work just starving back to when
yeah yeah he's like yeah but then dude
i'm talking a 30 minute
deep dive oh really on mma but that's
how people i mean people do that about
like i i hate that just say you hate it
i totally get it it's like somebody
asking me like you know hey so how do
you start in comedy hey hey [ __ ] off
if it wasn't chris's friend i probably
wouldn't you know what i mean he was a
nice guy hey go [ __ ] yourself man like
you can't skip steps yeah well the worst
is when they go i mean comedy how do you
even start in comedy i'm like oh we're
gonna start with the origin story yeah i
don't know dude i'm trying to you know
what you do in those situations just go
hey man that's a deep conversation yeah
and it's not for right now thanks you
know what i mean and they that some
people get it
i don't have that courage i went like
this is that cotton candy and then be
like
oh you think that's better
i don't know i apologize if he's
watching this now
is that cotton candy i was like we'll
talk later and [ __ ] beeline for it
hey chris let's take a little break from
chatting with our man eric griffin dude
i'm proud of you guys getting married uh
you gotta stay hydrated though we're on
the road dude and you gotta be hydrated
you're flying on planes you get all dry
listen i'm gonna get dry tell you right
now in fort wayne indiana july 14th to
the 16th and right after that i'm in san
diego at the laugh factory san diego the
heart of san diego daddy take us at
thickboy.com
oh that's amazing you gotta you know
you're gonna be dry you've got to stay
liquid yeah they say liquid you got to
stay dry you
you don't got to stay dry you got to
stay [ __ ] nice you got to stay real
nice and liquid and that's why my
friends at liquid iv dude 16 ounces of
water hydrates faster more efficiently
than water alone dude contains five
essential vitamins b3 b5 b6 b12 vitamin
c made with premium ingredients
non-gmo and free from gluten dairy and
soy and you know what makes liquid iv so
effective the science of cellular
transport technology ah my chick loves
doing this stuff i love it and i sit and
i do it with her and dude you know
what's crazy is you can they've got
flavors they put it in your arm and you
go and you taste yes
it's amazing grab liquid iv i just put a
little eight ounces water that my
favorites the watermen flavor all right
watermelon is my fave you can get at
costco nationwide you can save 25 off
when you go to liquidive.com use the
code kats at checkout that's 25 off
anything you order when you use the
promo code k-a-t-s
liquid iv.com experience better
hydration today at liquidity.com promo
code
hey chris my man i know you just got
married hopefully you celebrated your
special moment time at a wedding get a
nice diamond ring from my friends at
blue nine where would you do that blue
nile dot com yeah dude and they have
everything you need wedding jewelry
engagement rings they got bands everyday
fine jewelry diamond jewelry cocktail
rings gemstone gemstone necklaces they
got it all man they got it all dude
everything you need whether you're ready
to pop the question or you're just
looking for some diamond set errands for
your girl it's never a bad time to give
it to a man and here's the idea too you
can build the engagement ring of her
dreams right blue nile has simple online
tools that can let you choose the
diamond shape size and clarity as well
as setting style blue now's bench
jewelers will then build her perfect
engagement ring each is one of a kind so
you could tell her that and trust me
she'll be like
it is so that's great yeah you want your
girl to do that
make your moment sparkle jewelry from
bluenow.com and cats listeners and
viewers get 50 bucks off when you spend
500 this is a pocket podcast exclusive
all right so go you go to bluenile.com
promo code is kats again that's 50 bucks
off when you spend 500. all right every
order is insured ships free arrives it's
discreet little package nobody knows
what's inside right shop stress free and
find your forever piece go to
bluenile.com today
we've got uh a couple uh weddings okay
cool very small oh nice oh let's do it
no i want big ones
well yours is what it hasn't arrived
okay i've got another light for you so
you're not going for another one by the
way another light oh yeah you're asking
for the light yeah it'll be here next
week wear it up for there yes oh great
oh nice but i was gonna say before we
even go there by the way uh because
chris had a destination an expensive
destination wedding yeah yeah okay it
was you know well it was a drive but he
counted it as a destination i didn't
mind the drive because 800 a night hotel
i had to stay
so you're not getting a gift
i told her i was like man what about
she's like there's another one there was
another hotel they were all expensive
brothers
there's no there was no red roof
how about yeah i missed eric's wedding i
was on the road i was like sorry man and
i was like what can i do he's like i
said let me get your gift what do you
want he goes i want ps5
but i
so i was like yeah no doubt all right
i'll i'll get it i'll bring it to the
studio so i don't know video games i
don't play you know i got
kids i don't play [ __ ] video games
and so i hit up my brother i'm like yo
where can i cuz he knows all that [ __ ]
i'm like where can i get ps5 he's like
are you [ __ ] yeah you know how hard
these things are i know
but i thought he might have had a
connection
you know he'd get a ferrari you got a
ferrari connection you've got that okay
there's one in your ferrari you don't
even know about it yeah dude dig deep
you'll get a connection yeah you've got
to come back i didn't know it was
mission impossible i know i thought well
i actually didn't either i got i have
one
a ps5 right of course you do i have it
yeah if any of our listeners have one uh
i'll buy it from you 2k
that's okay
i'm helping you out no you're helping
you out you shouldn't even done it like
that you should know you could have been
like that's 500 and he was like it's 2
000 brendon
oh yeah that's the movie
bro
that's how he got where he is dude he's
crafty he's a business man he's savvy
last thing about your wedding i did tear
up when calvin was in the little tuxedo
that got me yeah and then your your
audio on your vows so sobered me right
up no my vows were good well i couldn't
i couldn't hear you
your ears are you know what i mean
i i heard him it was great yeah thank
you it was great i heard about a few
things about elevator that's it yeah
yeah
oh my god
chris told a very beautiful story he it
was it was a great story form vows about
an elevator and how his life is like an
elevator and
and like the different stops is all it
was it was beautiful it was like well
thought out and it was all the way out
of your emotions better than i did
because i was a blubbering man i was
shocked
i was shocked but the way it was because
the story was so it was it was like you
had to tell this story in a certain way
so it was great you didn't go for cheese
right where were you sitting there yeah
where are we sitting oh i was sitting
like on the right side like how many
rows up i was closer yes
they said like the back few rows it was
tough
yeah yeah i heard it in spots that's why
i was like all right he missed his
elevator i killed it
but i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna send you the audio i'll send
you the audio
you know it would be great it's like
when we do get it the video we have to
get the video and then play him saying
that
i was furious
yeah but anyways by the way i know we're
going on and on but again it was
beautiful i had two weeks and for me
i've had two weeks of love it was great
you know i i was in i i didn't even tear
up when i wanted to during your vows but
it was like towards the i think we
teared up at the same time
you know because it was like because i
had the visual in my head of like
what you were like and then the elevator
opened and then it was hurt yeah yeah
yeah and i was like this [ __ ] i
know it was beautiful i teared up when
calvin walked down when your dad started
giving a speech yeah yeah and her mom
gave her yeah she was great she's a
newscaster she was a newscaster i was
going to say her mom
it was long yeah it was long it was long
yeah when the bride had four endings it
was like lord of the rings
she's not she's not going to the mom did
subtle flexes which i enjoyed she was
like uh world champ
world champion cheerleader and i was
like oh small flags yeah yeah and she's
like and then she moved to venice or
like small flags and i was like i dig
this psychology degree yeah
no not not cheerleader gymnastics
and then the the bridesmaids got up and
they were talking about a vortex and i
looked at enrique and this one i uh had
uh uh ed uh ian cracking up i go uh
because enrique runs the laugh actor
give him the light give him a like
oh oh that was beautiful dude you want
the beautiful he go ahead i'm just going
i'm trying to interrupt you but i just
want to say one thing one thing i that
it's like when you know someone when
you're like friends with someone you
know their things and that someone tells
a story about them when you know them
well you're there yeah yeah yeah yeah
she told the story of like you guys
watching the hallmark yeah yeah yeah
yeah and like i was like i i was so had
joy for myself
because i was like of course chris
doesn't like hallmark yeah yeah so i
felt myself like i was there yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and i thought that was
yeah that was great you could tell she's
comfortable in front of her yeah
it's like she she was a beast she
handled it actually the mom handled the
whole thing
just even how she just she addressed
everything and just was like i really
felt a lot of love i felt that her
family really appreciates you and
accepts you and it was like it was
beautiful guys i'm telling you right now
you missed a girl we had to follow
[ __ ] yours dude yours was amazing so
yeah oh what's this this is eric's gift
oh
nice
why am i a bear though oh that's a good
one come on bro oh dude you know why
you're out there you know come on
in the in the gay community you're a
bear bro
hashtag gay pride look at this i felt
like you're very blue from jungle
book-esque that's why i like that i
picked a beard
that's awesome
i love the glasses that's hilarious yeah
that's fantastic yeah love it thank you
and then and then the i keep getting a
lot of comments about like they keep
saying like why don't they just add this
thing already
it takes a lot of work and then also the
glasses there's an e in there which is
very cool it's like your area yeah
yeah or it's an asian baby i noticed the
small things
might be an asian beer that
that's awesome
we just got to add that to the intro now
yeah
all right um and theo's dealing with
personal family issues so he's out for a
little bit yeah but he'll be back yeah
he had a
hit his son no
um yeah no he's dealing with his native
american son was finally born yeah right
right right right
and here he is is this the weekend
what's up the king the sting the wing
and the sing
i got a little debate club
i got a couple weddings coming up and
i have a few
females that are saying oh let me be
your password let me be your blessed one
and i'm thinking
i might just go with no plus one because
i don't want these you know to look at
these wedding photos later on and be
like oh who's ed with some random chick
yeah i'd rather just
fly solo so what do you think flying
solo to the wedding
or just bringing some random chick solo
daddy first bridesmaids you're a single
bridesmaids you're having fun
but also
i feel this dude he's got a bunch of
weddings coming up dude everybody's
getting married now because they're cool
for [ __ ] covid yeah it's insane i
mean that's what ours are back-to-back
and then the [ __ ] do we have so many
yeah do you yeah we have more this
summer like yeah it's crazy my cousin
i will say about this
at my wedding four of my
four friends of mine came up to me and
were like dude you got me thinking about
my ex
like like four of them did that they
just broke man it was like gloves in the
air at a wedding oh yeah yeah so i like
my advice to this guy is go solo yeah no
dude go i'm telling go solo yeah
like eric's talking about he's older or
you're just slaying dick from wedding
away i know because the bridesmaids
there's nothing makes more
i know but also dude don't you feel like
though when you're at a wedding it's
definitely fun if you're single and
there are other single people but like
there's this kind of like i don't want
to say sadness but if you're there alone
and like there's love in there
but it also depends on the wedding too
like you know we didn't you know i
didn't have the richie rich wedding you
know what i'm saying so it was like you
know where was yours at i'm saying we we
we did it we made sure to invite people
to rachel was clear if it's not a
significant other i don't want them they
have to come along so it's like not
everybody gets a plus one at a wedding i
think that that's good though i think
that like what she said rachel i think
that that's how it should be yeah if you
don't come with i don't think well we
didn't do that but if if you have a
significant other then they come if you
don't
then they don't bring them right because
you know what you're saying about the
pictures about the p what he's saying
about the pictures too my my girl was
saying she said the same thing she was
just like i don't want my pictures of
like so we're like well who's that girl
or who's that guy i think that that's
good
so it's like i feel like it's i think it
is something about you know what love is
in the air and you can meet people like
ian edwards at my wedding
he was doing good he he told me later
like yeah man we're not gonna i'm
putting you know
have you ever seen wedding crashers um
excuse me yeah somebody's at home like
what
but he went out and my wedding my my
wedding is weird too because like rachel
has a lot of model friends so it looked
like wnbc yeah yeah they were so tall
bro i can't believe how tall your girl
was oh no
that's all yeah her friends were like
there's five of them and they're all in
different colored dresses hilarious five
eleven six foot they're all like that
and then it was all
and all these weird comics yeah yeah
yeah all these short weird [ __ ]
trolls
yeah solo's the way to go also to that
point like the hoes don't deserve to be
at your friend's wedding like if it was
a close friend you can't bring somebody
well you're here to eat your food but
but also mean all the personal close
family and friends
you don't deserve that i don't know man
yeah maybe go solo but i'm not a slang
and dick [ __ ] idea because well you
don't want to be
i mean look if it happens and you get
laid that's awesome and that's fun but
like
dude you don't want to go with like
different chicks and [ __ ] and like it
doesn't mean anything also you look like
kind of a dick you're like yeah pay for
this one now i know yeah yeah this one
wants the salmon yeah yeah
yeah
wait what who are you bringing i know i
know yeah your food was tasty yeah oh
dude yeah the food
the the taste test was the [ __ ] dude
they brought it all out the stuff that
didn't make the cut even that was good
and you you guys even oh you know i
didn't eat the [ __ ] i left before the
cake was cut oh you're stupid because
after that there were churros out there
i saw the chicken chicken sandwiches oh
you don't know daddy has cavities yeah i
can't eat that [ __ ] that don't bother me
and tater tots there were tater tots i
didn't even get those oh no dude i drank
two up in there cold brew coffees
that was good huh the coffee was good
yeah i might have a
i might have a
you know a baby because of
his wedding
awesome oh that'd be sick
you put it in
oh god why is it so extra gross when he
does it
across the street like come on girl you
know what time it is you know what it's
mister nasty yeah we got to like we have
to combine all the names it'll be like
you know chris christine
alvin
[Laughter]
or your kiss was
pretty sex though the first sex
it was like was it a lot yeah
rachel made us practice dude
you guys just decided whether to do like
she told me we had to practice like [ __ ]
you know yeah that's cute she'd be like
okay we're gonna do it like this we're
gonna have one kiss and then we're gonna
do another kiss you know but she like
came at me it was like it was see but
here's the problem about going to
weddings because my girl went to
schultz's with me she didn't go to yours
because we couldn't find the babysitter
so i went solo like a loser but yeah
eric was kind of my date right but the
problem is
is when because me and her just got
married at the the
the courthouse
let's invest in the house what are we
doing yes but then
and then you know she's like oh this is
so nice like i was watching this little
girl i was like oh [ __ ]
and then she was like how is chris it
was all right yeah good kind of she'll
see the video and should be a [ __ ]
liar it's kind of boring dude have a
party surprise her with it yeah you
could i don't think she wouldn't want to
be surprised she's like
the idea
surprised me with the idea are you uh
well you can have like a you know what
you have a quinceanera at the same time
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah was there uh
well i could just set 60 grand on fire
you know yeah i know i know it's just
it's one of those do that anyway with
your dumb shoes
the vitriol yeah yeah how dare you
that's fair this guy man he's just
making sure she doesn't see this podcast
um make sure you don't know how much
these shoes are that i know
he got gold what you got gold shoelaces
and one and you don't want to spin on
the wedding
you are a piece of [ __ ] you're right
fair point how did both of our [ __ ]
mics break this [ __ ] well it's just
this thing pops off uh what's up with uh
new lights coming yeah yeah yeah what's
up with uh wait so was shaw's wedding
extravagant
no he wasn't as uh
his girl's parents house if they have a
house in santa barbara there's food
trucks for the food good good drinks
like you're super short fun
like if you have comics as friends
they're the best ones to give the
speeches oh yeah yeah they're fire yeah
they can read the room of course they
have their bombing they get out speaking
of so chris had a great pre-party
right
and then that was when he they made it
very clear this is when you're supposed
to give speeches yeah yeah yeah yeah
because you're not gonna be able to
write speeches right right
right and then his one friend goes up
dan yeah yeah
and just
nobody wanted to go up after him
no it was honestly
as a comedian so i went up and i gave a
um
whatever
when was this it was the night before
you were invited bro
so and so i was doing sets
so
it was a wine
what even it was like a winery like and
i was they were like you should say
something's like i'll say something and
i was like oh this is like you go back
to like open mics like oh i've done
[ __ ] rooms like this you know what i
mean and i'm like this is just a
terrible room
for
anything comedy so i'll just do a
regular speech if i get laughs okay i
did it i got a few chuckles i made fun
of my dad whatever and then uh i got off
and i was like if anyone wants to do a
speech
dan comes up doesn't know that this room
is just a
it's a [ __ ] death trap like for for
comedy and he went up with a few jokes
and it was a death trap so he was just
like and that was it for everybody else
everyone's like
oh i thought he crushed it because
everyone's like oh i'm good you're
kidding me so everyone's like i'm good
but you can't crush it yeah i mean
unless you're not set up for success
yeah even at my wedding like i i was
surprised at the people that went up and
i was surprised at the people that
didn't go up you know but at the same
time i look and i go i get it you know
what i mean like i was like did you did
you ever have a thought process that you
wanted to go up the whole time at your
wedding i was like i want to say i don't
know but that would have been fine i
know i know but at the same time i get
why you did yeah yeah yeah because i
thought the same thing too because you
know for me i was thinking to myself do
i want to go up and talk and the thing
is like
exactly that was what i came to i was
like exactly that's why i was out on
yours like when i saw the notes you do
well i'm like i have some fire [ __ ] in
my pocket right now yeah i'm like but
this isn't yeah but like you imagine i
just get up there no but hey chris but
even at the winery
even at the wine thing it's like i
thought to myself i'm gonna go up here
and i'm gonna crush yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and i'm like this ain't about me
yeah
and my instinct would be to like be
super funny
and i was like you know what this ain't
my time that's what i said i'm saying
i'm like oh this this isn't about you
dumbass because
i
dude i had to give a speech at my
brother's wedding i mean nobody heard
anything i was like anchorman in the
[ __ ] phone booth
like no one heard anything i was i just
couldn't get anything out i was just
crying but kristen's family was already
like chris is the funniest guy we've
ever met and i didn't want to crush that
you know what yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i
was like
realizing oh there's other really funny
people
i almost stood up i must stood up and
said [ __ ] take that comedian table
yeah
oh you had so you you i yeah it was even
during her vows you chimed in at the
perfect time but anyway i what i'm
saying though is i get as
a comedian in a crowd and having a
wedding and having comedians in the
crowd i i get why like a lot of them
didn't it is interesting yeah you know
what i mean yeah my table was so fun
though the comments oh yeah yeah oh yeah
it's fun i was with marshall craig yeah
those guys are great
glassman like dude i was laughing so
hard and then one guy i don't know
marquez was at our table unfortunately
i'm sorry
the one guy i don't know he yeah i guess
he started coming with he was the pink
suit he looked like a cocaine drug
dealer oh andy and he started dancing
when he started dancing i was like well
this guy's fantastic that guy andy
kozell is first of all always dresses
like hunter s thompson that guy is
one of the most fun guys to be around
like just he at a diner you're
i mean he's so funny dude and if he
could just talk to them
and he still does stand up right now he
does stand up i'm saying because i i'm
not there's no [ __ ] i just don't see him
around no no he doesn't he doesn't he
doesn't hustle you know but he is
[ __ ] [ __ ] him dancing i was
laughing my ass oh dude he's great how
about the band
oh my god where'd you find them yeah
they were such a good band oh dude
multi-ethnic too that
banned bro
dude first of all i hired him because i
saw the lead singer because the guy or
the no no no no the white dude the older
the leader he was the leader i don't
know what was planning
exactly
i just saw a picture of him and i was
like that guy is a wedding singer
we hire that guy okay he's a great band
that guy comes up to me before the
[ __ ] wedding i got to tell this on my
podcast too but that guy comes up to me
before the wedding and he is like hey
man i'm rick i just want a rich whatever
it was i want to let you know i'm so
happy to be here
um uh we're we're so happy is there what
kind of style do you want us to do and i
was like oh bro i saw your video do your
thing you guys are amazing do whatever
you want he was like is there anything i
could sing like we do kind of a classic
rock kind of thing and i was like it's
perfect do that do whatever you got just
play the hits you got and he was like
all right let me know and i said i will
but you got don't worry about it
he does he starts doing it the crushing
you saw right i was like this big i mean
they're amazing every song is like the
song that you hear on the [ __ ] show
remember that was the yeah it was 100
right
now
holy [ __ ] that guy that unbelievable
they're doing shout i hate that wedding
song and i'm like okay i hate that like
they're but they're good though right
hated that though they take a break they
come back they come out the guy says hey
man just want to say if there's anything
he's looking for i'm missing anything
yeah i'm like you should have been like
drake mitch no this guy's looking for
recommendations but i'm so happy with
what he's doing yeah so i say to him i'm
like listen dude there he is right there
i was like listen buddy you're killing
it just keep doing what you're doing i
love it and he said all right well just
let me know at any time i say i will
goes does another set
then comes back i'm sitting down he
comes up to me again and he says hey man
if there's anything you want me to say
this is the third time right this is the
third time he's cause he's all out of
song no well no that's not what it is
it's because he's been to other weddings
and he's probably been like later they
said hey how come you didn't do whatever
it is yeah right so i say listen man
you got this you're killing you're
crushing it everyone loves you be you
don't even worry about it he says
anything
so i say
brick house
i just take it out of my this is what i
say i don't even know why i haven't
thought of this song break out rick i am
not i like that that was in your wedding
i don't even know where it came from
i haven't thought about big house no you
did the math you were like i'm at a
wedding i was like i haven't heard that
one yet and he's like i don't play so i
say brick house and he go this is what
he does dude
this is exactly what he does i don't but
this is what he does he goes like this
he goes like this and he goes
oh
man
i love you man i love you i see he says
dude
yes thank you so much for letting me be
here and i said
of course man and he walks away and as
he's walking away he says
it feels so good
it almost like to the point where you
almost want to go hey bro
after seven attempts i still haven't
heard it i still haven't heard brick
house like what happened to breakout
dude it was the it was [ __ ] hilarious
on the comment card you put everything
was great
it just was looking for breakouts
that made me at the [ __ ] conversation
three times it was a waste
that's great oh you know what's great
about a wedding too because you know
someone you know someone like this like
i've known chris for years now but i've
never seen chris dance oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i called joyco i go uh
just like yeah people oh [ __ ] yeah
all your coolness gone i know i feel
like i ruined the moment you're gonna
dance and [ __ ] and you're all
yeah it's my wedding i was like yeah
that makes sense yeah you gotta dance
yeah i saw a lot of weirdos out there
like you know rick glassman can dance
bobby lee can dance your boy uh the
cocaine dealer from miami can dance
yeah like some people were dancing yeah
i know it was fun all right what we got
all right what else yeah
theo
eric
chris
and of course
the gringo poppy
himself
first off congratulations chris and eric
you all made a horrible mistake based on
my dad's previous three marriages
today i have a king of their sting it
for you
bringing your hydro flask to the open
bar to get filled up before the flight
home
i don't i don't like paying seven
dollars a little shot on the airplane
but i can bring 32 ounces of single malt
scotch for free
so can get or sting it
whatever i just said oh [ __ ] this guy
that's great
dude wow this guy's energy i love it
um so he
he's saying flask on a plane yeah
like there's this data i'm super close
with it my son jitsu i go today and he
he's like loud like
he's the only dad i talked to he's so
loud this last time i'm like what the
[ __ ] can we go get uh my son always eats
his pizza if he does good i go hey we're
gonna get pizza you wanna bring your son
he's like yeah i'll go he's so loud i'm
like bro you're loud as [ __ ]
he has a water bottle like this
pure vodka bro i'm like
what the fact that people think like
it's a flex or like you're gonna be like
yeah man well i just went why wouldn't
you share it
what's wrong you think i want to sit
through this [ __ ] yeah
like what are we doing here do you get
to have this fun time and that's why
you're loud as [ __ ] i always have a
thing with these kind of people though
like they don't like maybe well yeah you
[ __ ] if i sees your podcast and he's
like well yeah of course he wants some
but like he could have told me but like
dude there are people that like don't
like they they put themselves
on to you
and they're not receiving you
the way
you know you're portraying yourself like
meaning
i was at the coffee bean and tele if you
know how i do it there i [ __ ] used to
run this block over the cold water right
anymore though no they don't even have
it anywhere no to the point where it was
in your wife's vows
and i used to see this guy all the time
we used to talk [ __ ] you know me you
know me right this guy knew me we used
to talk all the time he said copy people
and then one day he says dude i got a
great book for you to read and it's like
this book on buddhism and i'm like bro
you know i'm not going to read that
because you know me right this whole
[ __ ] it was like the wedding singer it's
like why did we have that conversation
three [ __ ] times yeah people do that
but it's like yeah so people are pushing
themselves and you're like you're not
receiving me bro
no but i can't see what the thing is
like when you're in a moment like what
he's talking about you're with somebody
and like they're acting weird right yeah
yeah yeah yeah and then and then like
you get a whiff of their breath
that always just turns me off so much if
it's alcohol yeah because then i'm like
oh so one you're either like you're
drunk and not present yeah well yeah you
know you're like you're not present then
you're not aware of like and so then
it's like you're having your own
experience and you're bringing me into
it and i don't want to be in there
that's where i was at yeah yeah i don't
want to be a part of this why are you
shouting yeah yeah you've never shut
will you loudness
my buddy the other day we came to the
store uh ours of the improv and i could
tell like he was just acting weird
acting weird
hey man are you on drugs as shrooms
what
yeah bro it's it's a wednesday at eight
o'clock yeah yeah yeah this is from the
guy what time is it
i know it's 12 on a monday but you just
got it yeah well yeah scotch on the
table well it's not your thing but
shrooms
oh that's your line
well it's like
i won't say who it is but one of the
comics was like hey man you want some
opens up this it looks like mints at my
wedding opens up it's all shrooms are
you no no what no tomorrow's father's
day and uh you know we're just you don't
mess with that stuff i go
not when i get a drive home and be up at
six for father's day
king in this thing in the wing um
congratulations chris and eric on your
weddings um
you make a beautiful couple
uh debate club would you ever wear a
kilt to your wedding hell yeah and who
would have the best kelp pattern it's
individual to your family name so thank
you
thank you william wallace
that action is awesome oh i love it i i
really i wanted to go to battle i'll run
through the wall for this [ __ ] dude i
would have an off-white kill i'd stunt
on all your white with a hole
make sense though i i yeah i i think
that they're nice because uh i thought
like you sweat and [ __ ] and pants you
probably sweat less in a skirt like yeah
it's just open but it's it's tough
because it is a at the end of the day in
america we call it a skirt right so
unless you're harry styles you can't
really rock that [ __ ] not get beat up on
the streets
or you go to catholic school right i
would i would uh kilts make sense though
yeah i guess they do i don't know i
wonder if like if like you just came to
this world and you saw it as a man you
probably wouldn't think anything
feminine you know you'd probably just be
like oh you could you decided yeah yeah
yeah well yeah like if it's all i said
if all i fed my son is william wallace
you know like yeah you'd want to wear
one anybody oh this thing's sick yeah
yeah yeah and then he goes to school
like hey you're in a dress right that's
true i remember something that
influenced me when i was a kid the first
time the first time i you know that
like my mom wanted to go see raiders of
the lost ark oh yeah you know and i was
like i want to see this crap you know i
was just i remember this clearly being
like this is going to be stupid
really i don't know i didn't know yeah
you know what i mean i was like a little
kid yeah man when i got home i wanted a
whip yeah i wanted a hat yeah wow you
know and i was running around the house
yeah you know and so it's just it's that
kind of thing yeah influence you like
my hero growing up one of them was
arnold schwarzenegger and i thought i'd
look swoll if i got a flat top like him
so i went to the great clips and i was
like i want a flat top
really i'm like can you do it he's all
say less can't really do it and my hair
was
awful but i thought i looked like arnold
schwarzenegger he's on a flat top yeah i
used to have the i wanted the when i was
a kid i wanted the nine or two i know
luke perry jason priestley yeah dude
i'll send a pic in
it bro
[ __ ] off bro
well i'm with you on that i've been sick
i felt so good
with it man you don't even know don't
even get me started
yes
boy i had a duck tale back here like
that's you know what i mean bro i gotta
see that no we should get pictures of
what because i have a picture
that part is like you know i come from a
generation i know no pics i have to find
[Laughter]
hold on r.i.p to luke perry man i loved
that dude he was a nice guy yeah he was
great on uh he was also in um
uh he was he looks like brian oh yeah
yeah i know that's cool he looked like
brian if brian was on hgh for 30 years
[ __ ] no she uh he was on once once upon
a time in hollywood that was his last
movie oh he doesn't he was great on that
one he was on uh he does look like brian
he was doing well he was on riverdale we
were on a plane together and then he
died like
what do you die from being too handsome
i forget i don't know
he's good he's a good guy we get a dime
pieces what she was just talking about
it would end with a wolf she sent in uh
videos a couple times before she's a
stripper in cleveland oh that's right
she came out to the thick boy song on
the pole
what do you mean what's up guys congrats
on the naturals uh jessie here and i'm
here to bring you another king at or
sting it
so uh to give a little back story my
husband i recently had a vow renewal
ceremony in australia where he's from
and one of our friends gifted us a
commissioned drawing of one of our
family photos of us with our dogs here
uh nick i'm gonna need you to pull up
the side by side
everyone looks like i have down syndrome
this did not turn out great and
i just have to have you all hang it or
sting it what do you think of
commissioned drawings for a wedding gift
oh gang buzz buzz sore and sorry eric
i'm not going to sing for you
wait this little dime that's not
terrible drawing no that's terrible no
he looks like him but she looks but
brennan like she's on the spectrum like
she doesn't look good and she's gorgeous
yeah but also it it's still bad yeah but
also you have two wolves look at that
yes look at that picture but here's the
issues i know the pictures they're
insane i know but the issue is the
wolves no no but but no the issue is
like you have this person who's like an
artist
and they're making this thing for you
that is like on your special day yeah
and they're saying they're giving it to
you like this
what do you think right and it's like
it's supposed to be special and this is
like you know like what you do to a
sixth grader you put it on the
refrigerator right with the macaroni
paper what do you want me to do with it
frame it yeah
that's what i'm saying what do you do
that thing that's what she's asking it's
like it's a difficult you're put in a
difficult position well you don't say
anything you take it and you burn it but
the other thing is like you're not going
to beat that original
first of all
amazing [ __ ] grown wolves i don't
like how nobody's dressing no i the
other thing is they're in front of a
[ __ ] wall everything in that picture
is a dime i i thought that picture was
photoshopped it's real yeah i know that
picture is amazing you know what that
there the couple is so good looking
that the and then the dogs are so
striking
that put the dogs in the back because
it's
no you don't put the dogs because
they're not dogs you're right i hate how
no one's
like this is another dog's picture okay
you got two
dimes with two wolves dude in front of a
[ __ ] waterfall
you
[Laughter]
dude i don't want to hang out with
people that have wolves and live in the
wilderness oh i'm here these are these
probably these like like they're always
they're always like you know in like
sweatpants and like workout gear no no i
don't like couples oh i see you know oh
you don't like fit every time you see
them they're like this hey chris how you
doing
ten thousand stops it's only 9 p.m one
of those couples we're going rock
climbing like [ __ ] off you know what i
mean
it's like
it's just i
i
i'm not outdoorsy oh see i want to be no
i want to be like i mean they'd be at my
show a hundred percent yeah but they're
just like i just i i've been intimidated
by these type of you know if they were
swingers oranges and they're just like
they're not they're swingers they're
swingers no if i can play with the
wolves and like hang out and like spit
shop on workouts i'm in yeah they want
to go to movies you know yeah they don't
they probably have never seen movies
right i was aaron did you see uh eric
did you see every movie i know you've
been busy have you seen the new jurassic
park haven't seen it yet but i've heard
bad things i heard something i can't
wait to see it when i hear a movie's
awful i can't wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait speaking of have you watched
top gun nope not yet
top gun is unreal fantastic best move
i've seen in 10 minutes thank you
bro
kill can't wait to see it now you're not
going to enjoy it just do that
i'll be honest no you're not yes i will
you don't go in with a clear aircraft
it's so good you could go in being a
hater and you're dude i stood up and
[ __ ] saluted the screen yeah that's
great yes
that is a good song
only thing that's nostalgic about it is
the fact that they started the movie the
same way yes right but other than that
okay let me tell you what it like
there's no thanos in it okay right what
i'm saying is like it's just good acting
good story and perfect like
heartfelt
you know what it is tom cruise i believe
this [ __ ] and why do you but
here's my theory it's a great point the
reason you believe him is because for
the first time his career he's accepted
oh i'm older and he takes on that older
leadership role instead of being mission
possible 19 yeah
he wasn't taking a 22 year old no
sometimes you know what i mean it was
what's her name jennifer conley like you
know it was like it was you know what
i'm saying it was like tom cruise
he does this thing in his movies where
you know he's doing his own stunt right
yeah so you you look at it and you go
man you really are dedicated to making
this movie good so even though you know
this is like fake i appreciate the
effort that he puts in yeah this
[ __ ] is he's flying the plane
man he's taking off like he has i saw
him in the interview he's like yeah i
got my f-14 license i got my f-19
and he was like and i got my realtor's
license
no that's hilarious no eric for [ __ ]
what yeah you need more money
yeah you want to go see it two minutes
tom cruise is
trying to sell you this [ __ ] 350 000
house i'm buying the house i'm buying
the house he has that which is about a
man he got that thing no but eric did
you but that you know this goes back to
my thing that i always say acting is a
[ __ ] job dude it's easy as [ __ ] it's
so easy that you learn other jobs to do
the [ __ ] job because it ain't [ __ ]
[ __ ] here's here's the problem that's
such a good point no no no no no no no
no you don't don't win the movie
when the movie starts
wait it's ridiculous
you are ridiculous yeah i'm telling you
i'm selling us when the movie starts
before the movie and starts it's tom
cruise and the chair goes hey thank you
so much for coming to the movie theater
and i'm like what's up no me too
no original i was like oh this is gonna
be terrible he goes we were waiting for
this to hit the theaters because you're
seeing real g-force real jets we worked
our ass off enjoy the movie i went oh
that's cool and then check this out
miles teller was around jet so much he
got real sick broke out in hives had to
go in this oatmeal bath right and uh he
gets his blood work done next day comes
to set time goes you're all right man
what's going on and miles teller goes
dude they found jet fuel in my
bloodstream could have killed me and you
know what tom cruise said this is an
ultimate [ __ ] primo actor he looks
and goes you have jet fuel in your blood
and mouse telegraphios i was born with
it
wait hold on hold on do you want so this
is a bit different
a bit like
i would do like oh i can't do this
actually
they couldn't shoot for two days because
he broke out in hives couldn't figure
out what it was that he was allergic to
food or something they found out because
he was around jet so much somehow it got
in his bloodstream which is very
dangerous first of all i'm not happy
it's dangerous tom cruise hears it this
one's great tom cruise tears he goes i
was born with it
but he wasn't
he's just an actor
no he's you know what i disagree with
you tom cruise is not just an actor okay
he's got that thing and you know what
you know what i challenge you
you got a little bit of that thing too
that's why [ __ ] are out here
getting tattoos on their body with your
thing
so it's not just no view
it's not just about being an actor or
whatever it's when you have that thing
the only thing that can stop it or or
tarnish it would be like slapping chris
rock at the oscars yeah that's what
could like
alter it yes because that [ __ ]
had that thing too you know what i mean
but anyways it's a great movie
he
has that there's also pro america like
you know what are you from russia no
you're from russia no but that's why
that's why it's [ __ ] killing yeah
it's tricking you no it's not tricky
that's real dude oh my
dude i'm from i'm from [ __ ] i'm from
the corner of real avenue an authentic
street right and
real avenue authentic street yeah
so you're you're on the corner yeah
so stupid you're so dumb dude
what does aaron rodgers have to say take
your wife to i'm telling you i'll see it
i'll see it yeah because my dad was in
the navy was like and not only is it
good because he's like it's authentic
cause my dad used to work on uh he was
my neighbor yes on authentic street yeah
dude
all right neighbors on authentic street
getting married abroad obviously from
scotland
he went to vegas to get married didn't
invite anyone
just me and her was good that's cool
buzz buzz
whatever that kind of guys bro
avid listener so wait uh he got married
just by himself with the with him and
his girlfriend what do you say like that
he made like like destination wedding is
what he wants but also like but it was
just the two of them yeah
whatever fits your [ __ ] like if that's
the thing do it man i mean honestly i
made a courthouse bro if you i got a
buddy who's like the girl's like i just
want to go to the courthouse he's like
no i want to have a party i'm like bro
buy a [ __ ] house
i told my girl here's the thing when we
bought our house to go listen we can do
whatever you want to do or we can take
that money and invest it into this house
look at the salary get you the parents
paid for the wedding
i'm glad i had a wedding that's how it
should work oh yeah yeah i'm glad i had
a i look i look at all like
all my groups of friends who don't know
each other i i i was so moved by the
people that showed up and and it was
just like i was like this is great when
when are all these people going to be
together at my wedding and my funeral
you know what i mean you're not going to
be there for that one
so it's like i felt like this is a great
thing but i will say this all about
destination weddings oh yeah oh i'm not
it yeah i'm not yeah make it easy though
if it's a fun it is easy it's not though
here's excuse me here's where i'm gonna
be especially here no no especially as
torn comics like it's a knife yeah i was
able to go to yours because san
francisco had to schedule yours i was in
portland like it sucks i was so happy
though i got adam ray's save the date
and i'm like let me check if i'm on the
road i'm not on the road i'm like oh
good i can go yeah it is hard it is hard
oh so sorry that you two rich [ __ ]
can't make money that one day
okay
we're disappointing thousands of people
if we don't go hundreds of thousands
hundreds of thousands
are you kidding me what are you talking
about i sell tickets i'll be in by the
way i'll be in dallas ah that's what it
is i'll be in dallas workaholic yeah
hopefully there's no weddings
july 14th or 16th so i'm in fort wayne
indiana i don't know where i'm going i
haven't been thinking about it but my
point is that's all i think about i like
a good destination wedding because like
i tell you this i went to adam devine's
wedding yeah where was it at and it was
in cabo yeah and i haven't seen funny
[ __ ] greatest time and it was like one i
got the wedding discount on a really
expensive hotel so that was nice yeah
okay all right right so you got that but
then it was like just being with people
like oh we're at the pool we're at the
buffet oh no i had such a good time
even like you're like you could say what
you want you had a destination wedding
this guy [ __ ] thursday
it took longer to get to your wedding
than it did to mine no [ __ ]
we got there the day before and there
was a lot of traffic and i was in
traffic with rachel like this is chris
getting back at me right now
an hour the other thing is like
i i did i haven't seen marshall in five
years i did a movie with marshall i've
seen him since oh really i was in one of
one of his movies marshall's great uh uh
rick grassman i haven't seen him since
pandemic yeah yeah no no it's cool yeah
it's cool to see these guys
yeah
looking looking rich yeah yeah yeah
really
i know yeah he was like he looked like
and josh lieberman is there yeah i
haven't seen him in person i haven't
seen him in forever yeah i'm surprised
he was there
gotta [ __ ] it's all love that was a
good time yeah i felt like whoever was
there
they support you and love you it was
great yep and theo was dealing with some
family things so that's why he didn't
i just said to the i was like yeah i'm
sorry i wish you were coming he's like i
wish i could get over there man but i
don't know what he's doing i called him
on my way home oh yeah he was asked he
was like how was it man he said i said
you got my address and he never got back
to me so yeah when i was saying i was
like because i you know what my thing
was i'm not chasing anybody to come
together
you know i said hey you wanna come if i
don't hear back i'm like okay yeah i'm
not gonna be like hey man why aren't you
coming i don't you know i said can you
come if you can't come i don't care but
but i i will say this and this isn't you
know i was important i couldn't i get it
no i get it but i was like i couldn't
wait to like i know how much i love
somebody if i i was like excited to go
to yours i was sad i missed george other
people the weddings and like not
happening dude
i'll make something up i'll be like oh
man i got a piece of time it's fine if
you can't come it's fine but it's not
though it is i mean just at least say it
you know like i had people that were i'm
like
like you know chris was like are they
coming or not i'm like
you know and they just never responded
right and it's like that's so rude but
that's why i you know what for me i just
went i'm not going to worry about this
the ones that really like they want like
i like the workaholics boys didn't come
but they all told me why like blake sent
me a really nice yeah yeah yeah you know
what i mean yeah adam was like dude i'm
shooting uh what you call it and
anders's brother got married yeah on the
10th sure you know so i was like okay
yeah
but when when nobody when they just
don't hit you up at all no but just say
something about them even invited i know
i rescheduled uh san fran i can come it
was like a two day notice yeah yeah
that's i was like i don't need food not
just give me a piece of cake and whiskey
man it's also different because like if
you guys couldn't come you guys are my
friends it's fine like i [ __ ] i
understand we talk all the time but it's
like some people it's like oh
i i guess we're not friends you know
what i mean
i got to say something what i remember i
remember i five years ago i was on
bobby's podcast and i was talking to him
about like you know when you don't get
invited or learn about
one of your comic friends big life
events it makes you feel like you're not
really their friend after now getting
married i totally changed my mind on
that now so because i used to think
about like i thought i was really close
with sebastian yeah he didn't invite me
to his wedding and i was like oh man
maybe we're not friends right now i get
it
i get it it's just like you you know for
me we were in a certain budget i can't
invite everybody i just think who is
currently in my life all the time right
now let me invite those people right now
and it's not it's not a it's not a
slight on the other people no i do
understand that but what i'm saying is
if you get invited and you don't have
anything going on like and i i was i did
do a caption for the poster picture i
was gonna say anybody who didn't come
that's known chris and he invited and
for you for some whatever reason you
didn't want to show support [ __ ] all
y'all yeah that's what i want to put you
know it's like i i get it because like i
don't depends on the closeness level
like you know who you're really close to
because like we were going to go on our
honeymoon we had this whole big back and
forth i was like well if we go we can
come back and i wanted to go to the
party even before the wedding so we
we're going yeah yeah today we're
leaving
we decided to like i don't know so we
started it you know yeah since it was a
day
the people that you came up with the
people that you came up with that could
have made it didn't come
i'm out
yeah i don't know i mean [ __ ]
[ __ ] it depends on what it is and
what went down and what you had to do
but but but and and if you and and again
if you say i can't come that's fine but
for the people that are like you know
because krista was like are they coming
or not we had to know for the thing and
it's like they didn't even respond one
guy i texted a very you know close
friend owner for years and i was just
like are you coming or you know let me
know and he's like oh i didn't get the
email and i was like yeah but we also
sent you a [ __ ]
1
as well and then then you just go
no no no i'm out you don't want to force
them you got it yeah yeah don't tell me
you didn't get the email right the tags
i mean well
you know i got your address i guess i
invite
someone else
like you know and i was like yo
like a month ago i was like hey man yeah
you coming yeah you know it's just kind
of like i know you got this thing
i know you got to say oh well my girl
blah blah blah i'm like okay
that i'm out i'm just like all right
well then i'm not and then
i ask people one time
that's it no if it's important to make
it but as far as honeymoons how'd you
guys decide yours is surprising i'm
gonna go to london we're gonna go to
london yeah yeah oh you're bringing
yourself no i'm not no no
she was like on the outskirts are you
going like downtown now we're going
downtown bro
i want to do that
i don't want to do it you you how long
are you going to be going six days seven
days are you ready to be away from
calvin for six days no
i'm not surprised i'm surprised that you
guys aren't taking them i know i want to
you almost should take your parents and
just have them be yeah
i want to and where are you going eric
we're going to cancun okay my girl's
cousin she works for this luxury such
and such place that like does like
vacations and stuff so she got us like
we're still going to this like boutique
you know what i mean a thousand dollar
spa credit we're getting picked i just
go to the airport i want to be in ob
city i don't want to be and she was like
let's go here let's go there for like
yeah that's so weird i sting that yeah
the weather's awesome in la we're gonna
go to cancun we're like it's fine it's
cool but then you gotta eat you gotta
eat at the [ __ ] two restaurants they
have around there do you know what i
mean it's more than two i know but it's
like if if you're interested it's all
inclusive i know but that's where i
don't want to be i don't want to be
all-inclusive no me neither i want to be
i want to find a good coffee shop i want
to go out because she loves history so
we gotta go learn how to be in l.a and
he got killed he wants to be off cold
water that's what he wants for your
honeymoon yeah you're right i do but
she's like if there was like a hotel
next to the next to the [ __ ] coffee
bean he would be like oh this is great
babe i'm going down to the coffee bean
our honeymoon's in pasadena yeah yeah
coffee being in tea leaf resort
what else you got nick that's it that's
it that's good yeah holy [ __ ] oh my god
yeah well congrats fellas thanks if
there's anybody in london that wants to
[ __ ] do a tattoo by the way hit me up
i want to i want to get a tattoo they're
going to london um
that's something i don't know yeah
something like that means something i
want some more time and then uh i'm
gonna be i am gonna be in dallas i am
gonna be in uh denver at the bellco
theater get tickets at crystallia.com
i'm gonna be all the i'm in jacksonville
i'm in uh
kansas i'm in a lot of different places
uh boston at the wang theater so hit hit
it up yeah and then i'm back on the road
the trash band of summer tour start
kicks up july 14th 16th fort wayne
indiana new club out there and then i'm
in uh san diego the following week
that's in july that's the san diego
laugh factory the one where i opened up
for chris that's why i decided to do the
club it's a great club in the heart of
san diego laugh factory san diego and
then i'm in by august 4th through the
6th i'm in baltimore
and then it is
appleton wisconsin oh appleton wisconsin
just got added and then we have houston
in boston tickets at thickboy.com get
you some but uh fort wayne indiana let's
do it eric what do you got doug i don't
got a lot of stuff because i haven't
been thinking about it but i am going to
be at the creek in the cave in austin
july 15th through the 17th and i know i
have an irvine improv day coming up i
just forgot i'm just doing one night at
irvine cool and i'm gonna put i'm gonna
have all this stuff up once i get back
from get back from my honeymoon i'm
gonna be back to being
you know eric griffin the comedian yeah
i know i haven't thought about it yeah i
haven't even thought about it you know
what i mean because it's been so like
you know i've just been in a love haze
yeah i'm actually so glad you got
married a week after me it was just i
felt like it was like
i'm having the two weeks
yeah you know what i mean it was great
can i plug something no done this before
live show live podcast at irvine improv
july 13th me and my two buddies are
joining kate casey from reality life
with kate casey wow which is insane
congrats say out loud but everybody july
wow oh no
and make sure also that we issue a shout
out make sure you check out uh theo
vaughn.com right yeah
all over here
yeah so he's to be out someplace in some
redneck town so make sure you like look
for him and like you know and he'll be
on he's just handling his family
business he'll be back though yeah of
course shout out to mr theater they're
used to it at this point they don't care
all right guys love you
[Music]
it's the king and the sting and the wing
let's go
circle and put on the whole team
legendary trio bringing chris and theo
what you mean you know it's the king and
the sting and the wing
you